[Musique]
elle est pratiquement prêt à travailler
avec le magicien ya un truc qui me
fascine chez les dj producteur c'est que
c'est un peu les grands manitous c'est
pour ça que j'adore ce personnage de ce
nom parce que j'ai vu avec dj dj kore en
l'occurrence mais j'imagine que c'est
comme ça avec d'autres j'ai vu à quel
point il sent que les choses avant même
l'artiste avant même le rappeur c'est à
dire que ils te font venir en studio ils
ont déjà trouvé le morceau qui va te
correspond parfois ils ont même trouvé
la mélodie pour le rappeur en tout cas
je l' ai vécu ça sur les bo de mes films
ok vingt dix 10 mois ce qui te manque ce
que tu peux me rajouter le bit c'est un
peu là dessus plutôt rapide je suppose
bref est le moins agressif et puis c'est
assez étonnant de voir ces mecs qui
vieillissent mais qui continue à être
dans l'air du temps qui continue à
produire et tu vois par exemple un mec
comme comme dj kore comme d'autres
beatmaker il ya des générations entières
de rappeurs qui leur passe dans les
mains depuis qui s'était depuis lors ils
sont toujours là et ils ont d'équité et
facultés et des capacités à se
renouveler
artistiquement et c'est assez étonnant
donc je kiffe jouer ce personnage parce
que j'ai beaucoup de respect pour
pour ces mecs là quoi tous très belle
province avec tout le monde hein quoi
tuer tout le monde
ces approches au problème
l'ambiguïté du personnage de snow hill
vient de l'ambiguïté que j'ai pu aussi
sentir avec des beatmakers que j'ai
fréquenté qui sont des mecs qui doivent
être opportuniste c'est normal et
doivent sentir qu'avec quel mec les
inspire en quel mec filles d'ailleurs il
croit et parfois oui ça va provoquer des
problèmes parce que ils ont un gros beat
ou un gros hit acquis qu'ils vont
préférer donner à un autre mec et voilà
je viens donner mon son c'est la raison
pourquoi tu fais ça tu as donné mon
temps à me prendre pour un con
une création originale à découvrir en
avant-première en ce moment sur my canal